[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW GASPAROVIC: Hi, everyone.
My name is Andrew Gasparovic.
I am an engineer at Google
Research Europe in Zurich,
working on infrastructure
for machine intelligence.
And today, I'm excited to give
you an introduction to machine
learning using TensorFlow.
I'll start by introducing you
to TensorFlow itself, and then
show you some examples of how
we've been using it at Google.
And I'll share with you
a few recent and upcoming
developments, and
then talk about how
you can get started solving real
problems with machine learning.
So first, let's talk
about exactly what
it is that TensorFlow does and
why you might want to use it.
TensorFlow lets you
get straight to work
solving all kinds of
machine learning tasks.
The goal is that, in general, no
matter what your problem looks
like TensorFlow should
be able to support it
at some level of the API.
And in general, it's
designed to be fast,
so it's optimized for the
hardware and the platforms
that you actually
want to use it with.
One of the things
that I think really
makes it unique,
in terms of machine
learning frameworks, is
that you can actually
build a model in, let's say,
five or 10 lines of code,
and then take that
model and scale it
all the way up to production.
So you can train that
model on a cluster of tens
or even hundreds of machines,
and then take that model
and serve it doing super
low latency predictions.
So let's have a little
discussion about what
it is that I mean when I
say model, specifically,
and how machine learning
relates to that.
Here's a simple problem.
Predict whether an image
contains a cat or a dog.
This is something that would be
difficult, or even impossible,
to do with traditional
programming,
because how do you make a
set of rules that define
what is a cat versus a dog?
And then on top of
that, how do you
capture all of the variations
like breeds, poses,
and then the brightness and
the scaling of the image, all
of that sort of thing?
So what we can do instead
is make a neural network,
which is like an extremely
simplified version of how
neurons in the brain work.
Each one of the dots in
this image is a neuron
and they're all connected
together, layer by layer,
from the input of what we
see to the output of what
we understand.
And then what we do is, we
go through lots and lots
of examples of cat
and dog images.
They're all labeled with
the correct category.
And we try to make a prediction.
Initially all of those neurons
are just randomly initialized,
so it's a complete guess.
What we do is, we
calculate how far
we are from the guess
to the correct answer--
the error-- and then
we use that error
to adjust the strength
of the connections
between the neurons.
And basically, we want to slowly
move towards the right answer.
After we repeat that a million
or so times, let's say,
then what you end up with is
a nice cat and dog prediction
model.
But what you actually want
to do is build a cat and dog
prediction website, right?
A user gives you
a photo, and you
have to tell them whether
there is a cat or a dog in it.
And the connection
strengths that you
learned during training are
what allows your model now
to generalize.
So if you give it this
photo, even though it's never
seen it before and there's
no label attached to it,
it can get a dog
prediction out based
on what the model has learned
via those weights attached
in the neurons about the
nature of cats versus dogs--
at least in terms of the
images that it's seen.
But how much it
can actually learn
is a function of the model
size and the complexity.
And we just didn't have
computer power and the tools
to experiment with really
big and complicated models
until very recently.
This picture is basically
what neural networks
used to look like, maybe
five or 10 years ago.
And at that point, they had
a small number of neurons.
They were just fully
connected between the layers.
There weren't that many layers.
And the end result was,
they weren't super powerful.
In fact, for a problem
like computer vision,
they were almost written off
compared to a specialized, hand
tune model that was built by
experts for that exact task.
Now you can compare that
to a neural network model
that we use today for
image classification.
This is called Inception.
And the idea is that
you feed in an image
and you get a
prediction of what's
in the image among
thousands of categories--
I think it's like 17,000
potential classes.
And with a framework
like TensorFlow,
you can train a model like
this that has tons of layers
and is much more complicated
than the early networks.
That's what we mean when
we say deep learning.
The deep, in this case,
refers to a deeper arrangement
of layers, and the more
complicated connections
that comes with that.
The end result is that you
have millions or even billions
of neurons in your model.
And that's what allows
a deep neural network
to get results that can actually
vastly outperform the earlier
hand-built, hand tune models.
But the specific
reason why TensorFlow
is so efficient at working
with those huge networks
is because it turns
the code that you write
into a graph of operations.
And it's the graph
that it actually runs.
The data, by the way, that
flows between those operations
are called tensors, which is
where the name comes from.
And because your model is
represented as a graph,
you can do things like
delaying or removing
unnecessary operations, or
even reusing partial results.
The other thing that
you can do really
easily is a process that's
called back propagation.
So if you remember,
when we updated
the strength of connections in
our model based on the examples
that we saw, and the
error that we calculated,
that's the process
of back propagation.
Because the model is represented
as a graph of operations
instead of code, you don't
have to write additional code
for that.
You can just compute and apply
those updates automatically.
And another nice side effect
of having a graph around
is that you can, in your
code, say using a one line
declaration, I want this part
of the graph to run over here.
I want this other
part of the graph
to be distributed to a
different set of machines.
Or you could even say, I want
this part of the graph that's
very math intensive
to run on a GPU,
while the data input code
runs back on the CPU.
And TensorFlow runs on CPUs
and GPUs out of the box.
It also can load models
and run inference tasks
like doing a prediction
or a classification on iOS
and Android devices, and now
even a Raspberry Pi device.
And then inside of
our data centers,
we've been serving
TensorFlow graphs
using this specially built
hardware that we call a Tensor
Processing Unit, or TPU.
So doing that back propagation
and then applying forward
in the network the strengths of
connections between the neurons
for each layer--
that is basically very large
matrix math operations.
And that's something that
TPUs do a lot of very quickly,
very well.
Version two of the TPU hardware
we're calling the Cloud TPU,
and I will talk a little bit
more about that in a bit.
So once upon a time, Python
was basically the only choice
if you wanted to build
a TensorFlow graph.
And it's still a
perfectly great choice.
It's very simple.
There's a lot of
example code out there.
It supports everything
out of the box.
But there's also support
for a whole variety
of other languages.
And since TensorFlow
is open source,
there are a lot more
additional language choices
with community support that
are being added all the time.
And so the end result is
that if you're interested,
you can try out
TensorFlow in, probably,
your favorite
language right now,
and it'll work out of the box
And I just wanted to mention,
my coworkers on the TensorFlow
Serving team just announced
their 1.0 release last month,
which is a really huge
milestone for them
because TensorFlow Serving is
a very, very high performance
piece of infrastructure that
you can use to load your models
and then serve inference
requests, low latency,
on your servers.
Internally, we use it
for about 800 products.
But we really wanted to release
it as part of the open source
distribution because it's
such an important aspect
of a real world deployment.
That's one of the
things that, when
we say TensorFlow
is production ready,
it's things like this that make
the difference between code
that you write for
doing research and being
able to actually run
it in production,
solving real problems.
Another one is a tool
called Tensor Board.
So this is one of
the visualizers
that's included in the package.
This particular one is
showing a clustering
of hand-written digits
that a model learned
for that particular task.
In general, visualizing
what's happening in a model,
and then trying to
debug predictions
that you get out of
it, has traditionally
been a very difficult
aspect of machine learning.
It's kind of-- one of the
Achilles heels of a lot
of machine learning frameworks.
And so just like with
TensorFlow Serving,
that's something
that we really wanted
to include because that--
you wouldn't be able to
serve something in production
unless you were able
to actually understand
what's going on
inside of the model
and figure out if it
made a prediction that
doesn't match what you
expected, why that's happening.
And so that production
readiness in general, I think,
has really been one of
the keys to the success
of the framework, and one of the
things that makes it different.
TensorFlow, since its release,
has been the number one machine
learning repository on GitHub.
And it's really been
incredible to see the adoption
since it was released.
This chart shows the
number of stars on GitHub
since it was launched.
And the last time
I checked it was,
I think over 68,000
at this point.
And I think one of
the other reasons
is because we actually take
our place in the open source
community really seriously.
It's never been,
for us, a matter
of throwing code over
the wall or taking
a dump from our
source code repository
and just open sourcing that
and that's the end of it.
Open source and open
source contributors
have been a totally first
class part of the process
since it was released.
At this point we've
had more than 1,000
external contributors
on TensorFlow.
And some of those
external commits
have added huge new features,
like additional languages,
as I mentioned earlier,
additional hardware
support, and even
whole new platforms
that TensorFlow runs on.
And the other aspect
of our open source work
is making sure that users are
productive and informed about
how best to use TensorFlow.
So to do that, we've answered
thousands of questions
on stack overflow.
And we are also very serious
about looking into and fixing
issues on our
GitHub issues page,
because in general,
we want to have
a really seamless
experience from the time
that you download the
framework to the time
that you actually launch
a model in production.
But just to be clear, we use
TensorFlow a lot within Google.
This graph shows the
number of directories
in our source control tree
with models in them over time.
And the orange bar is when we
internally released TensorFlow
for all projects to use.
So you can see before that,
there was interest in machine
learning, maybe there was some
people white listed or using
our precursor framework.
And then after it was
released, it just exploded.
And there are more
than 6,000 products
at Google using
TensorFlow today.
And in fact, it's pretty much
every major Google product
is using TensorFlow and
doing machine learning
in some form or another.
And that has given us a ton
of feedback and opportunities
to make TensorFlow
better by doing things
like streamlining the
APIs that we provide,
adding new high level APIs over
time to make it easier to use,
and also just providing some
of the production ready tools
that I mentioned.
So let me show you
some of the things
that we've been specifically
using TensorFlow for,
because there's so much variety
in the types of problems.
It's, I think, a good
demonstration of how
flexible it is as a framework.
Google Translate used to use a
model that basically translated
word by word-- maybe a few
phrases here and there.
But that was basically
the extent of it.
And then on top of that, it
had hundreds of thousands
of lines of hand
tuned code written
with the input of linguists
and language experts.
Even so, it had a
lot of difficulty
accommodating all of the
nuances and differences
in human languages.
And so here's an
example, on the right,
of translating a particular
Chinese phrase into,
"where will the restroom?"
Which leaves a lot of
room for improvement.
We've replaced that
entire previous system
with a new deep neural
network based system
called neural
machine translation.
And that's running
on TensorFlow.
And the end result is that
many of the language pairs
have had huge gains in
translation quality, up to 85%
in some cases.
And the reason why
is because the model
works by considering a whole
sequence of words, a sequence
input and a sequence output.
And so the end result is that
you get a more natural sounding
output, much more like a
human translator would do.
For instance here, "excuse
me, where is the toilet?"
A much better result. And
sticking with that translation
theme, we added the word lens
feature to the translate app.
And this is actually
running on a mobile device.
It works in airplane mode,
which is pretty incredible
considering that it's
doing, basically,
a combination of computer
vision and translation
all in the same model.
We had to add
features to TensorFlow
specifically to make
things like that possible.
And now, you can train
a model on a cluster
of servers or one machine--
however you would
do it normally--
but then take that model
and reduce the size of it
to fit on the device while
keeping the quality high.
And then Google
Photos is an example
of an already great
product that was
enhanced by adding a machine
learning functionality to it.
So in about six
months time, the team
took that inception based
image classification system
and got it working
live in Google Photos.
And the idea is that you can
take a term and search for it
in your photos for
pretty much anything.
Like, you can type in beach
and get photos of beaches.
You can type in umbrella
and get a photo that
contains an umbrella in it.
Or even an abstract term like
sunny, without previously,
having added those
tags to your photos.
A more difficult
image based task,
using another deep neural
network, is this show
and tell model from
Google Research.
It takes an image
input and it outputs
a human sounding caption.
It also starts with
that inception model,
but in this case, it's not
just classifying the objects
that appear in the image.
It's actually writing
a caption that
sounds natural and captures the
relationship between objects
that appear in the image.
To do that, the
model was fine tuned
on examples of images that
had human generated captions.
And from that, it learned
about relationships.
As a side effect
of that process,
the model actually got
better at describing details
in the images like
colors, because it
found that those are things
that humans want to hear
in a caption that they like.
And so Google
Research, by the way,
open sourced the entire model
and there's an in-depth post
about it on the research blog.
And you can go in there
and follow the links
and try it out for yourself.
One of the other
things that we've
been doing at Google
Research is working
on diagnosing a condition called
diabetic retinopathy using
computer vision.
Ideally, you go to
an ophthalmologist.
They take an image like
this, and they analyze it
for early signs of
diabetic retinopathy.
That's important, because if you
catch the disease early enough,
it's easily treatable.
The problem is in
the developing world,
there aren't enough
ophthalmologists to go around.
And so it's hard to
catch it in time.
The end result is that it's
become the fastest cause
of blindness in the world.
So we published an article in
"The Journal of the American
Medical Association," which
shows that a computer vision
model can actually be as
good, or even slightly better
than, the average
ophthalmologist
at diagnosing the condition.
And so that's something that
we're really excited about,
because if we can get
the model out there
then it'll have a real impact
to help find more of these cases
before it's too late.
And one last thing
from the research team
is this problem of using
a deep neural network
to actually learn what
kind of architectures
are good for solving
different types of problems.
So what we're able
to do is do a search
from a poor performing
machine learning model
to one that's much
more accurate,
without any human
intervention in between.
The model actually
builds a machine learning
model that solves the task.
And those sort of problems
are called learning to learn,
which is a really exciting
area in the field of research.
And there's going to
be a lot more happening
in the next couple of
years in that area.
But just before you get
the idea that TensorFlow
is meant for long term research,
or is meant for big budget
blockbuster apps, I wanted to
show you a Japanese cucumber
farmer.
His son, in the back
of the photo there,
built an automatic
cucumber sorter
using TensorFlow
along with an Arduino
controller and a Raspberry Pi.
He trained the model by showing
it 7000 examples of cucumbers
in nine different categories.
And so this is a
job that his mom
was doing for 10 hours at a time
after every cucumber harvest.
And in his words,
he said, I want
to leave sorting to AI
so that we can focus more
on growing good cucumbers.
So after the model was
trained, he hooked it up--
he hooked up a conveyor
belt to the controller,
and an array of webcams
to the Raspberry Pi.
And so as each cucumber
comes along the belt,
it's imaged by the webcams.
It's classified, and it's
sorted automatically,
which I think is just a
fantastic example of something
really outside the box
that you can do practically
with machine learning.
And so TensorFlow
was, I think, really
powerful for solving all
of those sort of problems
as of the 1.0 release.
But there have been quite a few
new developments since then.
So let me just go over a
couple of those with you now.
First of all, it's gotten
a lot easier to use.
So I mentioned,
TensorFlow has always
been extremely
flexible with the goal
of being able to solve
any sort of problem
that you throw at it.
But it wasn't always the
easiest to use, necessarily.
It has the distributed execution
engine at the bottom there,
which is what actually executes
the graph of operations
and distributes them among
the processors and machines.
That has pretty much
stayed the same.
As of 1.0, then, we added
a layers API, with the idea
that you could construct a
model without having to actually
mess around with the graph
and operations directly.
But you still had to build the
actual network architecture
and all of the layers and
that sort of thing-- you still
had to do that part by hand.
And then we added on top of
that the estimator API, which
is a high level
way to take a model
and combined that with
inputs and do the training
and evaluation process.
Now as of 1.3, we
added another layer
on top of that for what we
call the canned estimators.
With a canned estimator, you
can create a deep neural network
classifier in literally
one line of code.
And then when you use the
high level estimator APIs,
you get a bunch of things
for free like distributed
training, automatic
snapshots, and the ability
to run on a mix of
hardware that you have,
like the CPUs and GPUs.
You also get all of
the best guarantees
that the performance
improvements
that we've been making will
actually apply to your model.
We've started
publishing benchmarks
of different tasks running
on different combinations
of hardware.
And that is important
because its going
to show how we're going to
continue to improve performance
over time.
But it's also important
because it can tell you
how you should expect
TensorFlow to behave
on the combination of
hardware that you have
and the problem that
you're trying to solve.
And as far as uncommon
configurations,
here's the Cloud TPU that I
was talking about earlier.
It's the second generation
tensor processing unit.
The first generation,
we only used
for accelerating the inference
part of machine learning.
The second generation
also accelerates training.
And it's a big
improvement in general,
because each Cloud TPU does
180 teraflops individually,
but they're meant to be
connected 64 of them at a time
into these TPU pods.
One pod is 11.5 petaflops,
which is just an enormous amount
of operations.
And the neural translation model
that I talked about earlier
used to take a full day to
train on 32 of the best GPUs
that we could get our hands on.
And now we train it to the same
accuracy in about half a day
using one eighth of
one of these TPU pods.
And the cla-- oh.
[APPLAUSE]
The Cloud TPU, by
the way, we're making
available on the Cloud
platform to external users
later on in the year.
And I'll have a little bit
more information about that
at the end of the talk.
We also need to make sure that
we're fully taking advantage
of whatever hardware you give
to the machine learning task,
whether it is a TPU or
the GPUs that you have,
or even just the instructions
that your CPU supports.
So we've been working
on a compiler that
converts those graphs that
I talked about directly
into assembly code.
It's called XLA, which is for
Accelerated Linear Algebra.
It's a requirement for
running on the TPUs,
but it also runs in JIT mode
to compile a graph for CPUs
and GPUs so that it
can choose exactly
the right kernels
for the hardware
that you have available.
And then there's a
third mode that's
meant for mobile,
where you can compile
a model ahead of time and run
predictions on a mobile device.
The advantage is that the
compiled model is much smaller,
but it still has the possibility
of running more efficiently as
well on the specific device.
And one last note
about mobile is,
we are working on
TensorFlow Light, which
is a whole new runtime
that's specifically built
for Android mobile devices.
The idea is that you
put a very slim engine
in a mobile app, which supports
exactly the hardware that you
have on the device.
And then it leaves out all of
the unnecessary general purpose
code.
When you combine that with
an XLA compiled model,
you get the efficient
use of hardware
with a small memory footprint.
And so you can do those
on device inference tasks,
like I showed earlier, as well
as something new that we're
calling Federated Learning,
where you can take advantage
of a model that's been trained
and is running in the Cloud
somewhere while having your
own individual training
data on a device.
So it's never sent to the
Cloud, but you can combine those
together on device.
Even if you have a lot of
programming experience,
I will readily admit that
getting into machine learning
can be daunting-- very daunting.
And one of the benefits
of trying out TensorFlow
is that the stuff that
you play around with,
you can eventually
actually use in production.
But still, I would
like to give you
some tips on how
you can get started,
no matter what level you're at.
First recommendation is to
start at TensorFlow.org,
because there's a Getting
Started section there
that has a nice hands on
introduction to TensorFlow,
as well as some machine
learning tasks that you
would want to do with it.
And they assume some
knowledge of Python,
for those particular
intro's, but that's about it.
And then if you
start with those,
you can progress all the
way through the tutorials
to building things like a
convolutional network which
is good for image
classification tasks,
and a recurrent network which
is good for those language
and translation tasks.
And then there's also a
really interesting demo
of different neural network
architectures and parameters
at playground.TensorFlow.org.
You can try varying
the number of letters,
or the number of neurons, or
the features, the learning rate,
and get an intuition about
how neural networks work
by seeing the effect on a very
simple classification problem.
And then once you start--
once you're ready to start
building real models to use
in production, I recommend
using that high level estimator
and canned estimator
APIs, because you
get all of those automatic
benefits like the saved
and restored checkpoints,
exporting the tensor board,
and the ability
to do distributed
training with pretty
much no additional work.
So nine times out
of 10, or even more
than that at this point, the
estimators and the canned
estimators are the way to go.
And then of course,
by using estimators
you could, if you wanted
to, move your model
onto Cloud TPUs down the road,
pretty much automatically.
And at g.co/TPUsignup,
there is a sign up form
if you're interested in finding
out more information about
those.
That link is also
the place to go
to find out about the
TensorFlow Research Cloud.
So we're making
1,000 of those cloud
TPUs available for free to
machine learning researchers,
because there are so many
people that have great ideas
but limited access to
the kind of hardware
to do the really state
of the art research.
So check out that
link as well, if you
would like to apply for that.
And finally, there are a
number of good online courses
for machine learning.
I'd recommend checking out
the Google Developers YouTube
channel, and also
Udacity has a course
called Deep Learning which
uses TensorFlow but really gets
into the theoretical and math
background of machine learning.
And if you like that course and
you want to continue with it,
then it's a good step
towards getting their machine
learning nano degree.
I really hope,
honestly, that you
do want to continue with
machine learning because it is
an incredibly exciting field.
It's more accessible than ever.
And there is so much happening.
I want to thank
you for your time,
and I hope you enjoy the
rest of your conference.